les implants mammaires à base de
silicone ne serait pas dangereux comme
on l'avait cru précédemment depuis plus
d'un an les soupçonnait de provoquer
bien des maladies notamment des cancers
aujourd'hui fini la mise en quarantaine
spécialistes américains et français
viennent de terminer des études
approfondies et leurs conclusions sont
rassurantes
florence bukiya bernard ap on l'avait
appelé la sphère des prothèses l'an
dernier aux etats-unis l'administration
américaine suspend provisoirement les
implants mammaires au silicone le gel
qui les constituent est accusé de
provoquer des allergies voire même des
cancers du sein la mise en quarantaine
devient européenne des milliers de
femmes concernées par ces implants
s'angoisse après moult rebondissements
la société européenne de métrologie
vient donc de rendre son verdict il va
dans le sens de la plupart des études
faites depuis un an
nous savons que les prothèses mammaires
n'engendre pas de maladies auto immunes
donc d'allergie eltern à ses prothèses
et ne favorise pas le risque de cancer
sur deux millions de fiamma moins de 50
cas d'allergie interne à la prothèse ont
été répertoriés quant au cancer du sein
c'est récidive serait même moins
fréquentes chez elle le suivi médical
très régulier de ses patientes explique
en partie cela
mais l'impact psychologique est aussi
très important ces femmes se sentent
ainsi reconstruit pour l'instant en
france le moratoire du gouvernement
court toujours
les implants mammaires en silicone ne
sont posées que pour raisons médicales
les femmes qui ont des soucis purement
esthétique devront se contenter d'un
autre type de prothèse